- What's next for you?
- Just kinda try to keep a hold on the job
in center
and be a leader for the guys on defense.
- As a rookie, you're
just trying to survive.
You know, your first,
your first part of the season,
it's like, “I want to prove I belong here.”
- Don't feel like you’ve gotta go out and
prove anything to anybody. Because
when you feel like you gotta start
trying to prove stuff to people or show
people, that's when stuff starts going
the wrong way. My first time up, it's,
you know, you're trying to get the
nerves out and all that kinda stuff.
My first time up didn't
really go too well.
That's when I realized that the
grass at Wrigley Field will eat up
any kind of ground ball. I don't know
if it's still doing it right now,
Kyle.
But if you get a chance, man, don't
hit the ball on the ground at Wrigley,
bro, cuz it will eat it up.
- Doc, Devin, you guys have talked about this.
So, as pitchers, you don't get
to hide. I make an error,
I get a chance to hit. You guys
give up a big hit in a situation,
manager pulls you out.
Fans are letting you have it. Cameras on
you all the way to the dugout. You
don't get a chance to hide.
So, when you lose that confidence—and
I'll start with you, Doc—that’s inside of
you, where do you go to get that back?
What do you do?
Or how do you get out of your own way?
- Aw, this is tough. I remember my first big league start.
I was in Houston, and my parents was there.
- [Announcer:] There are the parents.
They came over from Florida to watch
Dwight Gooden in his big league debut.
- After the game, my dad said,
“Son, what do you think?”
- I said, “Well,
I should win a lot of games.”
My next start was at Wrigley Field.
I got knocked out in the second inning.
I gave up, like, 800 runs. My dad
called. He said, “Son, what do you
think now?” I said, “Well, I don't know if I’m ready.”
First time you go through something
like that, it's a wakeup call.
Once you get out there, just hittin’
the first thing like, “Yo, gave up a hit too early.”
Then I started thinking, “Oh, man.
Here we go again.”
If I started thinking that way, then,
all right, here we go again.
But I said, “OK, let me just make quality
pitches.
Don’t try and make a perfect pitch.
Just make a quality pitch.”
And at that point, if I had a bad game
or whatever, I had to understand that
the fans, if they happened to boo me or write
something bad, it’s about my performance, not
necessarily me because they didn’t know me.
And I was able to separate the two.
Then I was OK. But it helped me in
the long run. You know, in, like, Year
2, Year 3, I was able to say, “OK,
I've been there before.
Let me just put that aside,
and let me get back
to what I do best.”
And go from there.
- Devin, let's
be honest: Guys get jealous.
You're having this success, and, “OK,
young fella, it's not gonna always
be this easy.” And guess what?
They're right.
How were you accepted in the
clubhouse?
- I mean, we have a great
group of guys, so it was, it was
nothing but love from everyone.
And, I mean, it was just a good support
system for me to have, especially being
a rookie, you know? There was times where
I didn't feel like I was throwing that
well, and there was a week or two that
I just didn't feel like me on the mound.
And, like, everyone.
that I talked to just, you know, they
were super encouraging cuz they all
wanted to see me do well also.
- And then comes
Kyle Lewis. I enjoy watching you play, what
you do, the way you go about your game.
And you’re a game-changer. Going forward,
won the Rookie of the Year, that's enough
pressure. But what's next for you?
- Just kinda try to keep a hold on
the job in center and be a leader
for the guys on defense. And, you
know, then at the plate, just
trying to have a simple approach.
Trust what I can do.
Bring some confidence to the
game and bring some confidence to the team
when I come up to the plate.
I try to embody that and try to,
try to be a leader in that way.
- I'm glad you said
that because, going forward,
that's what you're gonna have to do.
Day after day, people are gonna
look up to you. As a rookie with
this energy, you won this award.
Now, you're one of the leaders
on the team. Grow on that.
That's not pressure.
That's something you embrace.
I saw Ryan embrace it.
He inspired me. Understand that
you will inspire your teammates,
guys that have been around trying
to figure out how to get through
it. To see you have that success,
you will continue to inspire
them to be better themselves.
- Like he said, man, just
continue to inspire each other,
your teammates.
Just do what you do.
Like, don't feel like you gotta go
above and beyond. Just do what God gave
you, and you're gonna be all right.
And great things will happen, man.
Great things
will happen.